wait what you're not in the loop oh i'm
out of the loop apparently what'd you
guys forget
so uh
you guys forgot the main weapon wrench
left
so we're up here
and everyone is away from the studio
that means that nothing else is
happening except for this production
which is costing us a bunch of money
we're kind of behind schedule one of the
characters finds an m249 but the m249 is
still back at corridor digital
headquarters which is an hour and a half
away from here we forgot the m249 weapon
which is a great weapon that you find in
the game well we set up a little
operation called operation go get the
m249 i don't feel good about it it's
called someone goes halfway and someone
else goes halfway and they meet in the
center and it reduces overall travel
time
everyone just showed up this morning and
was like
last chance to get everything that we
need for this shoot sam's not happy
about it so i don't know where that
scope is
[Music]
that you can probably ask who's on the
rock and get nick right now how's it
going dharma okay so
he's rolling with the camera
i don't think we're as in as bad of a
spot as
sam thinks we're in all we have to do is
just create action scene first i need
your help with the crate okay so you
grab that i'll grab this start building
it
okay
out of fuel it's always something right
um
i don't i don't know if i ironically
even the right word there's a form of
irony in it there's a small form of
irony in there that they bring the air
compressor and the generator for the
purpose like two things that weigh about
like 100 pounds each and they bring them
both just to power
the nail gun but they didn't check what
kind of power the air compressor needs
to run but what's funny though is like
all they needed is take a nail and go
and secure the corners but instead they
decided to bring almost 300 pounds worth
of hardware to put a hammer in the nail
through some wood oh also on the top of
this all we have half day to shoot an
action scene they forgot a radio so i
have no idea what's going on over there
right now good thing everything's made
possible like red bull
well here's the problem nico said he
wanted to get a full uh like huge drone
shot and even the cars that we have
parked up here are in the way all right
give me a [ __ ] top or something to
this [ __ ] i'm just gonna put this thing
together i need that screwdriver with
screws that would be better
it's way harder than yesterday
[Music]
she just keeps driving back the lady
just keeps driving back and forth she's
gone by probably 12 times though
[Music]
it's really wide angle so it looks like
a really far here you'll never seen
what it we doing
hiding
basically
every single shot the camera's pointing
at a different direction so we're just
we're on standby you know but we're
going to hide in the meantime it's kind
of funny because the actors are
doing their little roundabout thing and
we're doing our roundabout thing around
production they're doing it around the
scene we're doing it around the camera
high quality h2o is much needed
i know you're soaked like i'm telling
you did i have to
i had to let this thing sit in the sun
for about three hours so it could dry
what's harder today is that this gun is
slung around it so it's super tight it's
like yanking everything down and putting
the
gabe what are you doing all right
playing sam so on action
uh
nico when you slam the pan say bong bong
give it some head room before the bongs
since he had to be shooting it
i had to be acting as sam so i'd be
shooting
to make sure sam was looked like sam was
in the shot this video is being saved
until the battlegrounds video is nearly
finished why because i noticed something
on set yesterday we shot the entire day
with shane in costume today we shot the
entire day minus
so
the question is the question is will
anyone notice because no one noticed on
set today will sam nico notice and what
will they do
if
they do notice subscribe and like find
out
[Music]
we just finished lunch what's the next
task for today shoot more videos